[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today let's go
to Kelly in Indianapolis Indiana Kelly
how can we
help uh hi I have uh I've been kind of
following the Ramy plan for just trying
trying to follow it for uh maybe about
uh a year couple year or two but I just
have one last credit card I just can't
quite seem to uh get rid of I don't have
a balance but I'm just trying to
convince myself to actually get rid of
it I love this and Kelly I'm I break
this down in the new book into eight
different characters so can you tell me
which one you fall into is it out of
fear is it for the rewards is it the
convenience what is causing you to go I
I can't cut this thing
up I feel like it's more like the maybe
the pressure of like everyone said like
you should always have one you're
because you never know if you're going
to get stuck in a situation where you're
going to need that okay so for you I'm
going to call you the emergency shelter
that's the sixth personality in the book
I need my credit card in case of
emergencies right probably yeah okay
well let me tell you there's a way
better emergency fund and it's where you
become the bank instead of Capital One
and that's called an emergency fund do
you have a $1,000 save for baby step
one uh I do I'm actually in a four and
six wonderful so how much money do you
have in
savings I have uh just a little over
like almost 11,000 amazing now tell me
when was the last time you had an $1,000
emergency uh never exactly so a lot of
this is paranoia there's fear we have to
deal with and the other piece of the
equation is you have insurance that will
transfer the risk you have things called
deductibles and outof pocket maximums
and so you're going to be protected and
you don't need these credit card
companies anymore they were never your
friend and it's just a rubber crutch and
it's only a matter of time before they
come knocking saying hey Kelly we'll
come save you at 22%
APR Kelly is the $111,000 does that
represent three months four months five
months or six months of your expenses uh
more like closer to three yeah is there
a number that let's say George and I
were were feeling uh like we could just
cut a check here let's say we were
having Dave's money here we like to give
Dave's money away I like that you and I
have done it a lot uh in our role that's
true we really have uh let's say George
and I could cut a check right now okay
and it would add to the $1,000 in your
emergency fund and when we cut that
check and you deposit it you would go
I'm cutting this credit card up I I feel
so much better is there a
number that we would add to the 11,000
be realistic here what's the number that
if we wrote a check to add to the 11,000
giving you a total of in your emergency
phone where you'd go okay I I don't need
this stupid credit card just curious
what's that
number I guess maybe uh maybe another
9,000 to make it 20 all right now George
you see what I'm doing there Absolutely
I'll give it back to you you're put some
facts on the security gland which is
largely feelings and we just said if you
had 20 grand you would feel so secure it
would be a force field between you and
life and that would be more like six
months of expens
correct yeah probably so then I I'm not
saying you have to do that Kelly but I
did a little experiment there because
that's what George and I are trying to
get you to I think 11 is enough for you
to cut the credit card up that's what we
think that's why we teach what we teach
should have credit up a l we should have
cut it up when you did baby step one
$1,000 that's what we teach but why not
then why not put the 9,000 in if that
makes you feel better and it removes the
Temptation I say go for it that's the
thing Kelly if if you cut up the card
today and an emergency happened what
would you
do you would dip into the emergency F
use the money yeah and that's what it's
there for and then once you use it what
are you going to do after you use it
you're going to replenish
it you know it didn't happen you never
went into debt you were never at the
mercy of the credit card companies who
are supposed to be blessing you with
your 2% cash back and this emergency
shelter and so I'm going to encourage
you to do the brave thing and what's
amazing to me Kelly is as people have
been reading the credit card chapter in
my new book they're telling me for years
we couldn't cut it up and you finally
coaxed us into it with all of the
research and humor and every objection
I've ever had I address it in that
chapter so I'm going to send you a copy
of the book and I want you to read that
and then send me a DM when you cut it up
with a picture can you do that for
me sure that's all I ask in return so
hang on the line Austin is going to pick
up and we'll make sure you get a copy of
Breaking Free from broke it's chapter
three specifically and uh Ken I want to
do another little mindset trick if I
might George I want you to join me on
this you are like the David Blaine of I
don't think but Kelly you said something
at the start of the call when George was
asking you what's holding you back from
cutting this up and what you told him
was what other people are going to say
to me cuz other people in your life are
saying Kelly you're a they're not
using that language but that's how you
feel but they're going Kelly it's silly
to cut the credit card up in case
something were to happen and so you
haven't cut it up because you're worried
about what they'll say but what
if what if something happens and when
they hear about it they're like what
what did you do you went I cut a check
CU I had it in the bank or you said well
I kept that credit card thanks to you
and I put it on the credit card I got to
pay it off quick because it's about 23%
interest which of those two answers are
your friends and family going to be
impressed with the most you tell
me probably the F the first
one so Kelly you're not going to be
viewed as silly Kelly you're going to be
viewed as smart Kelly by the very people
you're worried about and being
criticized by true or
false true there it is and guess what
those friends are normal Ken normal's
broke we know four out of 10 people have
nothing in savings 25% of people have to
use the credit card to cover the bills
that's not Kelly you've unsubscribed
from normal and fear is a terrible
financial adviser and so these credit
cards you know using other people's
money actually makes you feel less in
control because your body's keeping the
score it knows that you're not truly
safe when you borrow someone else's
money when you don't use debt you got
less stress create your free every
dollar budget today the simplest way to
budget for your life